all right let's check in now with mark
Strassmann he is in downtown Miami near
Biscayne Bay and as you can see the
winds they're gusting more than 65 miles
an hour mark good morning good morning
and so strong now Nora that moved in
from the middle of the street it was
just too dangerous it was too hard to
stand out there too many flying objects
as we all have heard projectiles are a
significant issue in these hurricanes
and this street out here is trashed with
palm fronds and all sorts of debris I
was went out to the middle of the street
to try to get a measure of how strong
the winds were blowing and was saying
about 50 then as I was walking back I
heard this crash and it was this sign
that had come flying down give you such
this thing would cut somebody's head off
if it hit them and it also occurred to
me that 24 hours ago this would have
been an appropriate time for the dilemma
that forecasters trying to track her
face was it going to go to the west
coast wasn't going to go to the east
coast and now of course we know to some
degree it's it's going to the West Coast
harder what is going to hit both coasts
and it's doing a pretty significant job
of that right now in Miami the streets
are completely empty whoever it has
remained behind has decided to hunker
down and with good reason
back to you all right mark thank you
very much it's clear it's changed just
in the last three hours since mark
joined us at six o'clock you couldn't
see the noticeable difference what are
you going to say well with street signs
flying through the air mark please
please be careful as you're out there
when we talk to the mayor of Miami Beach
earlier he said we definitely have not
dodged the bullet yet the winds are
still incredibly powerful very dangerous
nobody should be outdoors that said we
heard a citizen especially as we've said
all morning wide storm that's right we
heard one officials say it's getting
real and that was two hours ago so
please be careful and listen to the
warnings that you are getting